in this video we'll be talking about
coleric neurotransmission so obviously
we are going to talk about the atile
choline as a
neurotransmitter so when it comes to
neurotransmitter they are chemical
molecules that can transmit the signals
between two neurons so they are the
messages by which neuron communicate
with each other so they are there are
different types of neurotransmitters
like acety choline glutamate serotonine
dopamine norpin epinephrine and many
more but in this video our focus is on
atile
choline so in this video we'll be
talking about the coleric pathway in
human brains coleric neurotransmission
coleric
receptors and we'll talk about atile
choline from a disease
context so let's talk about the coleric
Pathways in the brain so when it comes
to the coleric pathway there are
different coleric Pathways and it all
starts from the
basal forbrain so the nucleus basalis
and the medial septal nucleus radiates
to different regions in the cortex and
the hippocampus and there is another
particular sector where the coleric
pathways are very prominent that is in
the pedunculopontine nucleus and
laterodorsal pigmental
nucleus so this can also project to
different regions including brain stem
cerebelum and selected location in the
cortex so now we are going to focus onto
the synapse and see the mechanism of
neurotransmission in bit more details
but before that let me quickly summarize
there are Basel forbrain coleric system
and Ponto molic tegmental coleric system
these are the two principal coleric
system in human brain question is where
do they project the first one projects
to several regions in the cortex and
hippocampus the second region projects
to Thalamus basal ganglia and some
portion of the cortex also the cereum so
the function of the basal for Brin ceric
system is
to promote learning and memory related
process it can help in working memory
formation it helps in cognitive
flexibility attention Etc the function
of the Ponto molic tegmental system
includes regulating sleep and wake cycle
arousal motor control it also modul
motor
activities so let's talk about the
mechanism of coleric neurotransmission
so here is the pr syapse in the pr
syapse atile KO gets converted with the
help of atile choline transferase into
the acety choline so the Coline atile
transferase is a key enzyme that
converts acety coin into acety
choline eventually acety choline is
loaded onto Vas with the help of
vesicular acety choline
Transporters eventually the vesicles
that contain acety choline will fuse in
the pratic terminal when the neuron when
the action potential reach the pr
synaptic terminal then the vesicle
Fusion happens and it and the
acetycholine gets
U gets released into the pre
syapse so then acetycholine binds to the
liated ion channels in the PO
and eventually it opens the ligated Ion
channel that leads to membrane
depolarization and that triggers the
post synaptic
events okay so now let me tell you that
acety choline esteres are enzyme that
can break down acety choline into
choline and acetate further choline is
reup taken by the preseptic terminal
which can be further be used to generate
atile choline
now let's talk about The coleric
receptors there are different kind of
coleric receptors there could be
ionotropic coleric receptors which are
fast which are simply Lian gated ION
channel they open when the ligan binds
and there could be also metabotropic uh
coleric receptors which are muskic
receptors which are slow receptors
because they are G protein coupled and
they require intermediate players for
the
signaling
now coleric neurotransmitter is really
important in context of nmj in
neuromuscular Junction nerve terminals
end into the muscle so the pre synapse
is the nerve and the post synapse is the
muscle now let's let me talk about these
synaptic bons which are zones where a
pre synaptic motor nerve terminal meets
a particular muscle so that's the
synapse so we are now in the synapse
it's a zoomed in view the process of
making aile choline is very similar that
what we have seen in the brain now let's
see the neuromuscular Junction uh how
the how it functions the overall
functioning of the junction so when the
vesicle fuses due to the action
potential there would be uh a fusion via
V snare and the T snare so when the
action potential reach the synaptic
terminal there is a huge amount of
calcium influx elevation of the calcium
influx triggers the V snare and the t-
snare Fusion that lead to the vesicle
release and the acti Coline is now
released in the cliff between the Press
synaptic motor Terminals and the muscle
now what happens is the post synaptic
event starts but also let me tell you
and remind you that acetycholine esteras
can get rid of the extra acetycholine
after some
time now let's look at the functioning
of the post synaptic coleric receptor so
as the they ligated ION channel when
there is binding of atile choline they
open and Lead this lead to influx of the
cation that makes the membrane more
positive and that leads to post synaptic
potential so post synaptic potential can
be recorded as excitatory po synaptic
current or epsp is excitatory poptic
potential change when there is a change
in potential there would be a change in
current now in the post synapse there
are other channels which lead to further
influx of the influx of cations that
might lead to a overall muscle
contraction so the key function of acety
choline in the neurom muscular Junction
is to trigger the muscle contraction
response there are specific threshold
for these contraction if the stimulus is
strong enough it would eventually reach
the threshold and it would lead to a
muscle contraction so this is really
important to understand now let's talk
about coleric transmission in a disease
context so this is how normal brain look
like in case of Alzheimer's brain the
coleric neurons are the ones which die
eventually question is why they
die now when it comes to myasthenia
gravis which is a autoimmune disorder it
is characterized by weakness of the
muscle and fatigue so in this case the
post Sy aptic coleric receptors are
targeted by Auto antibodies these B
cells are not supposed to make
antibodies against these atile Colin
receptors but in this disease there is a
mistake which lead to production of Auto
antibodies this lead to muscle damage
and weakening of the muscular
neuromuscular
Junction okay there are specific
antagonist and Agonist of coleric
transmission for example curari curari
is basically a potential antagonist for
the neuromuscular Junction especially
the coleric system the red Indians used
it for their poison arrow it would block
the particular post synaptic coleric uh
channels the nicotinic coleric channels
this would lead to muscle paralysis same
goes for latrotoxin this stimulates the
neuronal calcium channels and lead to an
excessive release of the acety choline
this is also detrimental for the
neuromuscular Junction leading to
paralysis so I hope this was useful if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support us more uh
using super thanks which is a hardship
icon present in the top uh bottom right
corner of the video click on that and
you can pay via PTM PayPal or UPI see
you in next
video